let's jump into that first story
breaking news
court orders jesse smallette released
from jail during his appeal after just
six days in prison disgraced empire
actor justice millett will be released
after serving just six days
judges sided with his lawyers who argued
that he would be finished with his
sentence before the appeals process was
complete he was sentenced to 150 days
after being convicted of five felony
counts of disorderly conduct for falsely
reporting a racist and homophobic attack
in 2019 smallett could have served just
75 days with good behavior he had been
kept in psychiatric care in a restraint
bed in the cook county jail yikes man so
as many of you are probably aware he
started yelling i'm not suicidal over
and over again which made many of us
believe that he was
and we did mention this briefly on the
show we mentioned it last time a little
bit
my view and i think is what you're
saying we agree
he was actually suicidal and by saying
he wasn't
he was hoping that people would think it
was a conspiracy because i got to be
honest his life's over it's been over
he's a joke well that's what i said on
air a couple days ago when we first
talked about the story granted it's just
speculation we have no idea what his
motives are but it sounded to me like it
was at least possible that this is
something a person who's planning on
killing themselves would say if they
were a complete egomaniac who wanted
people to think that there was some kind
of conspiracy behind it you know
there's something sociopathic about this
guy i mean when you have someone that's
able to literally like cry on demand and
go into great detail about the entire
hoax um and i you know i think this is
really tragic this whole news story
right because it's it's setting an
example the whole point of punishing
these people is to show society what
happens when you do something like this
and so he gets out of jail now after six
days there's gonna be a lot more hoaxes
and i think that that might actually be
deliberate on the left's part right like
they they don't want these hoaxes to go
away there was a
tweet
from i think was matt walsh
and he had a bunch of tweets from like
him and andy know and he was basically
saying
that he couldn't you know in almost
every circumstance these these hate
crimes where someone spray paint
something they turn out to be hoaxes
and then he shows this uh story
in four parts you know quote tweets from
andy know him and some other person
and you know he says i can't recall a
single moment maybe andy knows that this
in recent memory of one of these turning
out to be real
someone responded with you should pay
attention because this happened at emery
and then posts a link and then andy noah
is like the guy who did that was a black
the guy who wrote the graffiti and the
racial slurs was actually a black guy
so i got to be honest
yeah the only the only instance i can
think of that was was not
a hoax was like some kids in new york
used sidewalk chalk and made swastikas
and that was it
and it was like some little kids so
there was no real like direct attack on
an in a on a store or a person
i'm like no i think that one was like
actually maybe i'm wrong about that but
there was that story i remember that was
a former nfl player
had a a pizza shop and like a chicken
shop and then they were they were doing
really bad so he just ransacked them and
spray painted racial slurs and then you
know it happens and the thing about
these little kids i remember in high
school
my friends would prank me by drawing
swastikas on my notebook i'm not kidding
like it was like
yeah and we had this whole thing of like
edgy oh just just uh turn it into
windows right so like right little kids
can't comprehend nazism really like it
they they don't understand the gravity
of the holocaust and how terrible it was
and so like they prank each other with
that and that's
it's usually either a really terrible
prank from someone that's super immature
or a total hoax where someone's trying
to get more attention or get away with
fraud i think it's people just trying to
get attention there was how many
churches have been vandalized i mean
you've probably seen these stories right
yeah they'll put racial slurs in the
parking lot and then it was just like
it was it was someone from the church
like staging a hoax yeah no i mean it's
disgusting stuff i'm sure a couple years
ago you guys remember there was this
story at mizzou and within one of the
bathroom stalls someone had drawn a
swastika using fecal matter
and we were told that this was a
neo-nazi attack instead of first of all
extremely um unbalanced mentally ill
person to draw anything with fecal
matter but somebody who's actually a
nazi is not going to depict their like
sacred cherished symbol with
human crap right right
but the conclusion oh my goodness this
is a hate crime it was very bizarre
instead of like wow what a bizarre
disgusting thing to do it was this is
white supremacy you know it's hard
sometimes waking up and being like oh
that's the news again
because it keeps happening yeah with
these stories and and it's it's
remarkable that
you know what really is just it's kind
of depressing jesse's smallest being
released you know we thought we got him
hmm we got him he was he was arrested he
was caught we knew it he goes through
trial he is mocked and ridiculed more
evidence comes out it seems like a
clear-cut slam dunk case finally
convicted then we await sentence
sentencing and we're like please just
for once lock one of these people up and
they're like okay
you let them out six days later well
what are you taking out what are you
offering odds on that he gets another
like another acting gig
hollywood's going to take him back i i
mean i i would take so i would take
one-to-one odds on that really
definitely i wouldn't be sure one to one
odds yeah or i
one to one i would take one to one odds
that that he gets some type of
new tv deal or or
music he'll he'll come and repair his
image this is what they do he'll have a
whole apology tour right he'll come out
and say he was sorry he realized what he
did and how bad it was and then he
starts making millions again doesn't one
to one mean that you'd put up money and
win nothing if you were right no no i
mean a dollar for a dollar right so i uh
i plus 100 so is that it's two to one
doesn't it no no two to one is i put up
a dollar and if i win you pay me two
bucks is that what it is yeah sure
okay i don't yeah i think you're right
sorry yeah maybe i haven't been in the
casino in long enough it's been actually
a couple weeks
yeah so you think so you think so i kind
of thought his career was over i mean
he's a laughingstock
in a non-clown world i think i think
it's over but we live in clown world
that's well i mean also um so i'm not
sure if you guys are familiar with brian
peck but he was convicted
i believe of raping a child and he was
brought back to work at disney after he
served his sentence so
um oh no i'm sorry so yeah abc slash
disney hires convicted child molester
brian peck to work on children's tv show
uh one year after he's released from
prison so the idea that they're above
hiring jesse smallette is yeah that's
true and they gave you know um was it
roman polanski oh yeah yeah and who's
the other guy who's the other guy what's
his face
the newer guy right who was joking about
pedophilia on twitter
no no no no no the other guy with the
glasses
oh i can't remember what's his name he's
a famous famous guy famous guy with
glasses i got nothing sorry director
producer or whatever steven spielberg no
no
i don't know enough about movies and
stuff yeah
yeah i don't know but yeah like with
whoopi goldberg they brought her right
back and i'm still flabbergasted by the
fact that andrew gillum is still a name
in political circles after what happened
with him absolutely is he really he's
still around yeah he's rehabbing his
image he's repairing his marriage after
that that's why that's why sometimes
that's why i say like i wake up and i
see the news and i'm just like how about
we go and talk about
you know a doughnut factory instead
because it's it's just i'm sick of how
do people believe this stuff at this
point how do we how do we sit back and
allow these kind of things to happen and
you know it's just kind of mind-numbing
yeah well you know ian mentioned this
the other day that i had said to him the
way i define elite is as a person who's
never going to face any consequences for
their actions and we see that in the
case of jesse smallett he was sentenced
but then he's let go after serving six
days so honestly i guess those are more
harsh consequences than a lot of other
people we would consider elite would
ever end up facing but we shouldn't be
surprised that he's let go because what
he did
was try to forward the narrative that
they're constantly trying to promote in
the media woody allen racist woody allen
didn't he do something with his sis or a
daughter or something there was
something really screwed up with him
yeah people are mentioning james gunn
too yeah but yeah but james gunn was was
trying to be an edge lord and failing
yeah he thought he was posting you know
obscene jokes about children would be
funny and people were like bro that's
gross stuff don't do that so that's it's
different if you if you think you're
being edgy you know and it's not and
it's bad like i'll be like bro that was
bad don't do it again i think that's
right but you know like roman and woody
and justin
yeah yeah that's kind of like yo those
people shouldn't be welcomed back in
this place yeah that's cancelled culture
justice mullet should be canceled
exactly this is hilarious because every
single time anyone on the right points
out that a person has done something
terrible the left goes
i thought you were against cancel
culture as if that's any kind of point
against our argument that you shouldn't
comb through someone's tweets from 12
years ago and then try to cancel them
because they said men are men
right
that race car driver's dad who said the
edward in the 80s yeah and so sponsors
canceled him that's so insane some
things should be canceled right like
there's a reason why we have laws in
prison and like some things should have
a stigma to them yeah but i think the
problem is it always comes back to this
one issue where it's just you know
institutions and even conservatives take
these people seriously
and i'm just like
why
stop contracting with them stop working
with them stop servicing them stop
hiring them stop being hired by them
just tell these unserious people to go
away like if i out there there was a
comic book store like a game shop and i
see the big blm fest i keep walking yeah
and i'm like i look up on google and
it's like we sell magic the gathering
cards and comic books i'm like i'm gonna
go check it out and i show up and they
see a big sign in the window and i just
turn right back around get my car and
leave yep i'll order it online dude i'm
not going to give any service to these
unserious psychotic cultists just just
not no i'm sorry these are the these
people are the reason jesse smallett
gets away with this right these are the
people who cheered for every single hoax
every time
they always fall for it and it's it's
not even they're falling for it right
now no no it's part of the plan right
well no no they continue continue but i
have a point i want to make about
falling forward no i just think it's
part of their plan they want division
they want chaos they they don't they
want us
withdrawing from society and not
participating right and and i think that
it's really important not to fall trap
to that but also to figure out how to
not support them and give them
legitimacy yeah so it's interesting
because i think you're right that they
don't fall for it because to them it
does not matter whether something is
true or false what matters is whether it
maps under their ideological world view
because then in some subjective sense
it's poetically true so it's okay for
them to promote it and it forwards their
goal which is overall good and noble the
people who fall for it are the
conservatives who don't immediately say
this sounds ridiculous and it's probably
bs because we're afraid that there's
some slight possibility that it's a true
story and we don't want to be labeled
racist the one time it may have actually
happened
you know what i think
i i actually i agree with you
i don't know if jesse smollette is going
to get work right so so they're going to
let him out of jail maybe his appeal
just fails then he goes back to jail
they're saying it's only going to be 75
days so you know two and a half months
with good behavior
i don't know if he gets rehired to act
but
i would actually be willing to bet
that he would get a reality tv show oh
yeah following the saga
i mean
people will watch it or not why not a
cnn gig right
i mean that's how
fundamentally unserious those networks
are yeah i don't know about cnn i think
it would be interesting to see them
bring them on because he's friends with
don lemon but they they they you know
cnn as bad as they are they don't want
to you know punch holes purposefully in
their ship if it sinks well here's the
thing but hold on look you know what a
and e or amc or whatever what's the
channel that has the weird a e a e yeah
they're gonna be like justice millett
reality show and it's gonna be him
sitting down and be like i didn't do
this i gotta call my lawyer and they're
gonna follow him around people would
watch that because they hate him so so
that's his opportunity and he's gonna
i just book
he's going to go find the real hoaxer
yeah um
i think that you guys are
underestimating how good of an actor
jesse is he's just going to slip jesse
i'm sorry he's gonna slip into a new
life somewhere become a different person
and he's just gonna blend in wherever he
is because he's so talented that way and
then there's gonna be some beloved
celebrity 20 years from now who everyone
worships and he's gonna go it was i all
along jesse and i fooled you with my
incredible acting skills isn't it crazy
though i mean look at when he went on
was it abc
how he was it abc did yeah 60 minutes or
so 60 minutes he manufactures perfectly
these these tiers yeah this performance
well that's what i'm saying he is one of
the greatest actors of all time of all
time yeah that was the whole thing he
says
i mean this the whole thing was a demo
tape for him he comes out and he's like
i want to admit that i staged the whole
thing and the court the trial that was
the performance that was the problem
i'll be in jail i'll be out in two
months
call my agent very avant-garde piece of
art do you remember when walking phoenix
did that thing no he like quit acting
and then started rapping and everyone
was like what is he doing what's
happening and then it turned out that it
was a big stunt yep i remember that
that's that's probably just a smell
that's best bet it was it was a big stun
i was just joshing you guys i was
trashing around all right i was happy
he'd probably go to jail for a lot
longer if he said that
because right imagine i mean the phone i
don't think so i don't think he's ever
gonna see prison time no i think
actually if he admitted that he did it
and it was a hoax and he did it for
acting he'd get less time he'd get an
oscar he would know he would get less
time in jail because he's only he's
getting 150 days
even though he's refusing to admit what
he did was wrong yeah he's still denying
it so they're you know they're giving
him that penalty the idea is there's
something called the trial text you go
to trial you get a harsher penalty
because the idea is the idea is really
that you're wasting the court's time so
they punish you but the idea is supposed
to be that you haven't learned your
lesson so you need more time in jail
well and then to put it cynically the
other idea is if we make people feel
more afraid to go to trial then we can
just sentence people for crimes without
actually giving them their day in court
yeah so they'll they'll pick him back up
maybe yeah i mean at the very least it's
not something we would ever put past
them
oh man yeah isn't it depressing though
i guess i mean if you ever had any hope
in hollywood i suppose or the legal
system
that's fair that's fair oh man but it's
also chicago i mean i'm oh yeah that's
fair i'm from illinois so it's
yeah it's tough as are we it is yeah
yeah
yeah yeah would it be just it would just
be so funny if it turns out that this
really did happen and the cops staged
all the evidence to like
you know just make him look bad it's
like the worst white supremacist hate
crime that's ever taken it turns out
that the two white dudes who attacked
jesse were actually like off-duty cops
goes all the way up to trump even higher
goes all the way up to putin and it
actually is my country and we just we're
making fun of this poor guy no one no
one tells you this but cook county very
red
very very incredibly red yeah yeah deep
red county yeah it's just a city right
extremely red no it's a little bit
outside of the city some of the suburbs
or cook county well illinois itself is
red yeah just chicago well who is it
that said there are no uh there are no
red or no blue states only blue cities
yeah
that's right that's true and there are
red cities which is interesting but the
interesting thing about chicago is that
it's not even blue
it's
zombie
you you have like illinois growing up in
chicago you have the zombie contingent
and the republican contingent and
republicans you know they can vary from
very ignorant to very knowledgeable
but the the people in the cities who are
voting democrat are the zombie
contingent 99
and that's that's what i grew up around
people who are just like vote blue no
matter who and i'm like who are you
voting for don't no don't care as long
as as long as not a republican i'm like
the city has been run by democrats for
80 plus years and it's worse than ever
no it's doing really well just worse
than ever and it's funny too because we
used to have uh do you guys know what
lotus is
it's like someone
on the south side of chicago
these guys pull up with carts full of
corn
oh
yeah they'll take the corn
and they put mayonnaise parmesan and
cayenne pepper on it and you eat so good
or i would always have them they would
they cut the corn off into a cup and mix
it with mayonnaise parmesan and cayenne
they got banned in our neighborhood
terrible but only like they couldn't
cross cicero on the south side because
when you cross so this is the
fascinating thing about the midway area
from like harlem to cicero which is a
few miles from 47th to like 63rd was a
generally white polish immigrant and
like whiter area when you crossed 47th
to the north side it was all black uh
community all black housing when you
cross cicero became all like latino
so the city for some reason banned the
elotes guys from coming into our
neighborhood but they could still like
they couldn't cross cicero and that was
the weirdest thing to us because we were
like so the guys who sell corn who are
hispanic can stay in the hispanic
neighborhood but we like the corn we
love those guys they took it away from
us
it's almost like they wanted the
segregation yes and here's what the
funny thing is like there are certain
things that like break down cultural
divides right like it's food it's music
it's uh you know movies uh literature
and and i do think there's something to
that like this whole like anti-cultural
appropriation thing is really meant to
keep us from participating in other
cultures and being open to it and and
breaking down those barriers like cinco
de mayo is a great holiday because
everyone likes tacos and it's not like
denigrating to like the mexican
community to celebrate cinco de mayo
like it's a good thing to participate
catholics are really good about this
right like we take over and baptize all
these like pagan holidays and make them
ours and it's it's beautiful it's it's
that's that's colonization we're not
giving them back
ever
ever you guys not even christian trees
that's what we're told
which i didn't know i've had people tell
me that they're like you know when you
worship easter you're worshiping your
fertility god it's like i didn't know
that
interesting i didn't know that i guess
well but i guess you know better than me
what i'm doing
you didn't realize that you were you you
didn't catch yourself when you were
praying that you were actually saying
fertility i know it's
but yeah no it's uh it's true that there
are a lot of things from other cultures
that can be sanctified and people from
different cultures are able to relate to
each other
and part of the problem is because
racial tensions are so high and we have
really stoked the flames of genuine
hatred along ethnic lines people are
afraid not only to participate in other
people's cultures but to even engage in
humor that might be targeted towards
other groups even in a more playful way
and i find it interesting because i
think you see this happen sometimes
every now and again you'll meet that
couple
who make jokes about each other but you
can tell it's in like kind of a stabby
sort of way they're really being
sort of uh crass and snide to each other
and it's very painful for everyone who's
there but then you have some couples who
can kind of poke fun at each other and
it's really funny and everyone enjoys it
i think what happens is as a
relationship between two people or a
group of people breaks down humor goes
from something which can be cherished
and which is very endearing and helps
bring them together and it turns into
something really insulting and the same
exact joke can be really funny coming
from a person who you have a good
relationship with or really uh offensive
coming from someone who you don't and so
i think i think uh breaking down racial
relations people ask why everything's so
pc i think a huge part of it is we just
don't trust each other
i was just thinking you know about the
cultural appropriation stuff and the
protests remember that video where the
the girl at prom or whatever she wore
the um chinese dress yeah
what is it called
kimono no that's japanese
it was called it was chinese thing and
um people in the chat will tell us what
it was called so i'm i'm forgetting and
then people in china were like that's
cool like they actually really liked it
and i thought about i was thinking about
this there's also the video where the
guy's got dreads and the black girl like
literally grabs him and she's like
you're stealing my culture and he's like
what are you talking about and then i'm
like how come these people never protest
taco bell
yeah why don't they show up to panda
express well also as if like there's one
ethnic group that just owns dreadlocks
right that's not true though i mean the
vikings had it yeah exactly that's why
and and you know i know a bunch of
people in scandinavian countries who
have dreadlocks because of like they had
dreadlocks but it's like people have
hair dude right people can do what they
want to their hair
hair styles no that's our do no
intellectual properties yo taco bell
bears no resemblance to actual mexican
food that's exactly right hard shell
tacos burritos burritos aren't a mexican
thing and and and cheddar cheese what's
going on here that nacho cheese is not
cheese
powdered cheese
uh panda express now i'll tell you taco
bell is delicious
it's almost worth the bottle obstruction
panda express is also delicious but man
they're just chunks of sugary fried
chicken and it's yes but it's good but
i'm not going to pretend it's actually
chinese food
you know thai food in this country is a
sugary fatty americanized version the
same thing with like all of these
different foods and you know what people
love it right yeah so if these people
want to go oh i'm i cultural corporation
is wrong stop ordering pod thai on
grubhub i know you're doing it because
it's like the number one food on grub up
or it's in the top five or whatever
pizza it's italian what gives you the
right mm-hmm no one's protesting these
things you know what you ever noticed
that no one ever
starts an irish food chain like an irish
food
that's not like a large national thing
you know you don't have it and every you
don't have a bunch of them in every
single city we have scottish we wish
some people would appropriate that part
of honestly no i'm glad that we have you
why don't you make oh donald's
mcdonald's it's an irish name you go in
there it's got irish food no it's mc
it's when it's m.a.c it's scottish
when i went to the uk they told me it
was scottish what did those brits say to
you yeah they're gonna tell you more
colonizer lies about ireland
bro
look it up i think you're wrong oh maybe
i hope not because if we lose mcdonald's
we have nothing left
in the united states
i often have like a stupid dad joke
where i tell people like what do you
want to get i'll be like do you guys
want to get irish food like oh yeah
there's a good place to make um
mcdonald's and everyone laughs i did
that in the uk and they all looked at me
and they were like that's scottish and i
was like no it's mc and they're like o
is irish mc is scottish and i was like
is it that's not true no mc is is irish
mcnamara is my mother's maiden name and
they're all from ireland yeah yeah yeah
they were they were colliding
yeah of course they did thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there